au bout d'un moment parce que je vous
dis ça parce que moi j'ai eu un flot
d'insultés voilà
pour faire une mise au point aussi oui
voilà donc voilà j'ai 30 ans je
m'intéresse à la politique je suis une
citoyenne engagée j'ai le droit de
donner mon avis quand j'ai vu ce qui
s'est passé ce week end alors vous étiez
tous tout à fait tranquille moi c'était
un des pires week end dans la vie j'ai
jamais j'ai eu des milliers d' insulte
des milliers de menaces pourquoi
pourquoi parce que les médias ont fait
leurs choux gras de tout ça en fait ils
ont découpé des choses je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas regardé tout le tpm p ils ont
découpé et au final ils ont dit elle
fait la promotion de marine le pen mais
en fait ces pages pour ce jeu moi je
suis une si juste une citoyenne qui est
déçu si je faisais la promotion de
marine le pen j'aurais peut-être fait la
promotion de cette candidate au premier
tour ce que je n'ai pas faim sauf que
maintenant au deuxième tour il ya une
personne où il ya une autre on a déjà
essayé une personne ça ne me correspond
pas pour ces raisons là voilà mais je
dis que je suis une ancienne miss france
j'ai jeu ça fait dix ans que je véhicule
les valeurs de la france qui pour moi
sont la liberté de pensée la liberté
d'agir la liberté de m'exprimer la
liberté de m'habiller je veux dire tout
ce que je veux c'est pouvoir m'exprimer
sans qu'on m'insulte alors que moi je
veux le meilleur pour mon pays et j'ai
entendu ça fait et et moi tout ce qu'il
a de l'avenir la motivation pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas diaboliser marine
le pen avant maintenant que eric zemmour
est sorti maintenant au second tour on
l'a diabolisé c'est la seule arme en
fait qu'on utilise parce que eric
zemmour servi à ça voilà c'est clair
qu'un entre marine le pen et zemmour je
voter marine le pen je m'en cache pas
l'approcher quitter le pays mais je vais
vous tuer marine le pen voilà évident
parce qu'on nous a envoyé le pire marine
le pen c'est moins pire mais c'est pire
il ya toujours pire non ça me va pas
mais après savez moi je suis athée donc
je suis très à l'aise voilà mais j'aurai
la religion pour musulmane pour moi elle
est culturelle l epa cultuelle c'est la
religion de mes parents je la respecte
ma maman fait le ramadan je respecte et
on nous a beaucoup à ostraciser
notamment à cause des attentats je veux
vous dire deux choses moi d'abord
j'étais l'éditeur de charb et de tignes
où ce je les ai lancé je les ai connus
et fatalement j'étais affecté lorsqu'ils
ont été tués par des gens qui ont un
prénom qui ressemble au mien par des
gens qu'un physique qui ressemble à
celui de mes cousins et je peux vous
dire que pour toute cette génération les
coups qu'ils prennent d'un côté et
ensuite être associé à ces gens qu'ils
relèvent pas de la religion qui relève
de la psychiatrie pour moi plus de la
psychiatrique de la religion je peux
vous dire que c'est pas facile c'est pas
simple et surtout les gamins à l'école
après les attentats du 11 septembre
après les attentats à paris pourrait que
c'est facile d'être un gamin et comme
prenant étrangers à l'école alors qu'on
attendrait la journée des djamel ou quoi
elle est non moi je suis pour une
société inclusive je crois on est une
grande famille bien sûr que tout ne va
pas bien bien sûr sur les gilet jaune ya
beaucoup de choses à dire je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le pass sanitaire
ya beaucoup de choses à dire je suis
d'accord avec vous mais le président
emmanuel macron il a patiemment il n'a
pas eu un un mandat facile on est tous
d'accord pour le reconnaître crise
sociale léger donc et gilet jaune avec
l'egypte en demi et c'est une guerre non
mais la pandémie c'est la seule chance
il est jeune et non l'équipe est jeune
c'est pas de sa faute c'est le résultat
de deux dizaines d'années de 2,2 de
nullité des comme elisa de ça c'est pas
de sa faute sur les attendiez le comité
sepa dès la fonte des neiges et les
jaunes sont aphones philippe les
manifestants gilet jaune et rouge
c'est que les personnes aujourd'hui à
cause de cette pensée unique parce que
les gens ont peur de s'exprimer et ont
peur des insultes que j'ai reçus via une
pensée unique soit je voyais tout sauf
démocratique et que les gens qui étaient
dans la rue il ya deux mois ils vont
voter macro et ce sera les mêmes
personnes qui seront à nouveau dans la
rue et à quelques temps il ya quelques
mois mathieu tu disais oui c'est pas la
peine de faire des manifestations
bientôt il y aura les urnes vous pourrez
manifesté à ce moment là clairement sauf
que là les gens deviennent nouveau
amnésique en fait ils préfèrent
manifester dans la rue puis précédant
les élections puis à nouveau dans la rue
et c'est sa maman qui me dérange parce
que c'est plus de 60% des personnes ne
ne sont pas du tout d'accord avec cette
politique là pourquoi est ce que un
nombre très conséquent votre est à
nouveau c'est ça moi en fait que je que
je comprends pas en fait